I mean with some of lecturers local
dignitaries but as a guest start piling
in
that's in Alex's cooking begin to show
giving the alias Laura has every other
yeah
what is talking about the food I mean
we've been in here mail our not very
happy about this and we reorder and have
breakfast instead Alex seems to be
forming at the first hurdle just on
really really really quiet you know
there's only one man who can get us out
of this mess and help salvage Lanterns
reputation
Kevin please parmesan right Kevin
kitchens in the strip yeah yeah it's a
big night tonight like we should be in
the ship hello
yeah how many think we have you sold
yeah so in order to have the kitchen
start pushing the [ __ ] linguini
little but yeah so we can take a bit
away off Alex's shoulders you know and
push the suits as well something we can
really start flying start us out please
yeah let's go I want Gavin to show some
bottle if you can motivate his team a
star selling the ready prepared specials
and that will take the pressure off Alex
and get the kitchen back on track